all right and we're good up the back all
right excellent so let's kick off
welcome everybody uh thanks for coming
to my talk and I wanted to start off uh
this morning just saying that building
consistent you know reusable code and
maintainable code in the front ends it's
freaking hard uh I've been doing this it
is huh like for really big companies
it's really hard and I've been building
front-end applications for everyone from
large organizations to startups to
massive government organizations
um and we always end up in the same
place chasing the same things uh so
today I wanted to share with you my
journey to the holy grail and and how
I'm building uh micro front ends with
reusable web components and design
tokens and look at some of the the
challenges that you'll face and see
whether or not this might be something
you want to take you know a real good
look at at and whether or not it's
actually a path you might want to walk
down so my name's Duncan and I've been
kind of pushing this space of of
front-end development for over a decade
now and I'm pretty excited to share with
you you know some of the latest
adventures in this space
um around this topic so why web
components well I work for at the moment
I work for the federal government and
we're building their next generation of
reusable components and their design
system so for us it's all about this we
want to be able to have web components
that we can run in lots of different
places so we want to be able to run it
in angular we want to be able to run it
in react we want to run it in
help us Adobe experience manager we've
got content Management Systems who's
using AEM here
okay it's pretty popular no one
um but we've got it you know it solves a
problem for us definitely but we need to
be able to run it in all these different
sort of places and we're pretty bullish
on web components for that reason like
Brad Frost would say in this space he's
bullish around web components if you
have this problem but there's another
problem that it helps us solve and that
is we're doing micro front ends
so for us we have something like this
where we want to run all of these web
components in all these different
Frameworks also on the same page so we
want to have like a CMS wrap this with
using this blue web component button
here in the top we also want to be able
to do this with uh having like a section
in the middle that would be a micro
front end for angular and then we want
to do it again for react all on the same
page so these web components are helping
solve that problem for us also but we
have another problem that I want to talk
about today and that's having reusable
Styles and that's where design tokens
are helping us solve something like this
where all of a sudden we might need to
change say the primary color for our
brand the business gets together yeah
we're going to change this happens
mergers policy changes we're going to
change from a blue color I've got to
check this blue to a green color
so
how do we actually do this in in the
wild is normally we would in a bigger
company we would hit up the design team
and would say to them hey uh can you
send me the link to your design tool I
need to get that latest color and you'd
go over there and you would find it and
you'd probably copy it and you come back
to your code base and paste it in there
and that might sound like a small
problem but we're all as developers very
aware of copying and pasting and the
challenges around that so for us design
tokens like this which is just a key
value pair of some design token like
color primary set to a variable and we
conversion it we can put it in code is
really helping us because if we needed
to make this brand change we can just
simply put a new value to it bump the
version ship a new package and all those
Downstream people can then use this
design token so
these were all it's simple yeah this is
all the same stuff we've been doing in
code for years but being able to apply
it to some of our Styles so we're going
to be talking more about these today and
and how we get them into our code base
but we have many different Design
Systems we don't just have one we've got
lots of departments and that means more
than one design system and those Design
Systems are used by more than one team
and those teams have more than one
project and those projects have more
than one repository so it gets very meta
for us to be able to support all these
environments that we can't just have one
react for everything so this gets quite
challenging and you might be sitting
here today going well
I don't quite have that problem at the
moment as a Dev I've kind of got two big
apps maybe and they're all in one space
all in one framework but hopefully this
gives you a glimpse of what it would be
like if you're traversing around and you
create to what you would be in for if
you were to go into a really matter
environment like this
and we've got heaps of problems this
isn't unique to us this is all big
companies we copy and paste code between
our micro front ends we have angular
reacts and you name it cms's Android iOS
lots of places that need those design
tokens
and we have a constant stream of new
projects starting all the time I get
called every day hey is the new stuff
ready do we use the old stuff do we use
new stuff they're always trying to not
recreate the wheel
and we have ever evolving Design Systems
which is good you know even when we pick
up something to build you know that
design system is changing over the
two-week period of us doing you know the
first cut of some component that we're
building so you need to be able to keep
in Pace with all of that we have release
deadlines all of our feature teams they
can't stop to solve this problem for
anybody else so we've got all the normal
big problems that a big company would
have
and they have to be accessible these
components that we're building you know
we can't afford as a large business to
be able to ship anything that's not
highly accessible so we need all of
these things
but it's not our first rodeo this is
actually our third go at this we've 2017
18-ish we started off with one in react
and then kind of a year or so later
another team started off one in angular
and these are hugely successful used by
dozens and dozens and dozens of
commercial well not commercial but
dozens of teams to ship production sites
but inevitably they've gotten kind of
end of life and now we're starting a
third one and I kind of think that's for
a few reasons one reason is
um they're siled to angular react and we
just have too many different platforms
that we have to support so we can't just
rewrite into react or angular and the
second thing is the web's really evolved
you know it's very easy to ship a
website at the moment that will now this
year
um there's 50 kilobytes the shipper web
page to the browser whereas in the past
you know that was a lot harder to do and
these older kind of kits that we have
you know they've got fonts and all the
Styles and it's kind of it's hard to
just use a button and just pay a little
bit you're going to pay a lot if you're
going to bring in some of our older ones
and I think the third thing for me is
it's two design two developers Centric
we kind of the developers had the say in
everything and they built most of these
kind of component kits and Design
Systems in collaboration with the
designers but not enough collaboration
and for that reason now a lot of that
secret sauce is just baked into this one
Downstream section of code and it's very
hard to get buy-in and it's kind of
naturally dying for that reason and I'll
talk a little bit more about the team in
a second so start of this year we kicked
off we're about six months in we got the
team together we got buy-in for us the
restart with web components and design
tokens and have another crack at this
and we're just at the point of piloting
what we've got so that kind of
terminology of like piloting your work
like a TV series coming from Dan Mile
and Brad Frost
um some voices in this community so
we're not at the very beginning it's not
our first rodeo but we're definitely
kind of relearning a whole bunch of
stuff as we go here with these new
technologies
so what are we going to cover off today
we're going to talk about the team that
you need to pull this off we'll talk
about why web components a little deeper
of why web components we'll talk about
stencil.js which is the component
Library we use
talk about how do we get our design
tokens into code how to we do it as a
team and then we'll talk about the tools
and packaging we're using because it's
very different than shipping a web app
we don't have a web app so what do we
use to actually do everything
so talking about team structure who you
have on the bus is really important for
this you know to be successful in this
space you're going to need to have the
right team and if you just grab a couple
of full stack devs and start building
components
you're not going to build something as
awesome as if you have a designer or
designers and you have a specific type
of front-end developer
so I really like this quote from Adobe
it's kind of over two slides they go on
to say you know digital experiences are
collaborative you know you need this
shared language and it's this shared
language that becomes the design system
across developers and designers and it's
used to be able to talk about you know
colors character Styles and components
and I like this because it's talking
about design and devs you need these
people on the team but also puts me in
my box as a developer because components
are just this little part of this bigger
picture and they're kind of Downstream
which you'll hear me talk about so you
really need this cross-cutting team so
you'll commonly see people they banter
around about this saying hey you should
you have a team that looks like this
this comes a lot from Nathan Curtis
who's very popular on medium and he'll
be like you need a designer you need a
developer you need this kind of like
glue person that's kind of between
design and Dev and project management
and for me in our team that's me I kind
of I definitely code and I help but I'm
also kind of responsible to make sure
I'm getting out into the broader teams
and making sure we're going to be making
something awesome for our stakeholders
but this front-end developer or we've
got two others so we're kind of muscled
up at the moment which is good but you
want to front of the front-end developer
so if you think that I mean a back ends
for front ends pattern which I reckon
Jason might have been thinking you're
not the front-end developer that I'm
looking for I'm looking for a front-end
developer that has a certain set of
skills for making these low-level
components
so I'll share these slides afterwards
this is a link to people talking about
this but you know Brad Frost and the
storybook team banging on about this
front of the front-end developer that
you need so you really want them to have
these skills you know focused on styling
accessibility you know HTML this kind of
low level stuff whereas this back end of
the front-end developer you know they're
kind of more of a traditional developer
they've got to focus on patterns and
builds and outputs and Speed and
Performance and architecture and all
those sorts of things but it is really
important because they're going to spin
their wheels if this is the first time
they've ever built their own custom
select and they have to deal with
keyboard navigation and those sorts of
things so you really do want to think
about the type of front-end developer
that you you get on your team
but we have an extended team
um quite lucky and I probably should put
our accessibility peeps on the other
slide because they're really important
for us and we're really lucky we have
three of them they're not in my team but
we can counsel them and they can help us
well they help us at the very beginning
even just deciding how we're going to
build a component but then they help us
when we put them all together and make
sure that we haven't stuffed anything up
but they're really important for us our
Architects are important you know they
sold the story and now we have to
deliver it but they've run off as
Architects do but we also need our
project teams our project teams need to
dog food this we need to pile it with
them we need to build these under
pressure of actually trying to make a
web page rather than trying to finish
all our components and then come back
and you need the Internet like it might
sound funny but all of this stuff around
design tokens web components you know
it's kind of one two year-ish people
been talking about it so if you're going
to be in this space you really are going
to need to be research heavy and look at
what a lot of other companies are doing
because there isn't just one book to
pick up or one pluralsight course and
you're like I just spent eight hours and
I know it now and your company is going
to be unique because you're huge and
you're going to have to come up with
your own way of doing Secret Sauce and
blend it in with what you see from
everyone else so it's definitely a
research heavy sort of space to be in
you're going to have to go look at what
a lot of other people are doing
web components so why are web components
for us we touched on that big Point
already for us we want to be able to
achieve this we want to be able to have
angular react and so forth but I want to
run through some of the
the kind of details of why web
components make this possible and also
share with you some of the prickly parts
of web components that aren't so great
um but in in general like I said we're
very bullish so we want to be able to
run it everywhere in all these different
Frameworks
but to be clear it would just be heaps
easier to do this in react honestly
um
or angular
is that okay yeah okay
um so I'm not married to anything in
terms of Frameworks I love them all um
but it would be much easier just to do
this if you're a shop that's just got
one or two really big sites it'd be much
easier to just do this in that platform
because you're going to be able to go
get amazing libraries that have already
solved all the component problems for
you like in the react space you've got
like stitches and headless UI and all
these other sorts of things chakra UI
that you can apply your design tokens to
and and your design system too and it
might even also be easier just to have
two copies one in let's say you're a
you're gonna get in trouble here from
the front row but angular and View and
it might just be easy even to have two
copies if you're big enough of those
design of those components but at the
same time that has its own challenges
it's not easy in big companies we've
gone down the path of work components
so this is what they look like if you're
going to use a vanilla JavaScript word
component you don't have to read all of
this but you can see at the top and you
know we're making a hollow World
component that extends HTML element if
you skip all the middle Zoom to the
bottom you'll see a P tag that we're
returning that's just the word hello and
some name variable so I'm just going to
pump out onto the page hello hello
Duncan or something like that now this
will run anywhere
it's a web standard I just open a script
tag I use the I Define it for the
browser using browser standards and then
I can use that HTML element and it works
which is great ironically you never get
to write vanilla javascripts like this
because we all use a framework still or
a library to write our web components
but they compiled down to this web
standard and you can use them everywhere
so you kind of get the best of both
worlds
and it's based on three standards you've
got HTML templates which gives you like
my Hello World component and then you've
got your HTML templates which give you a
template markup and also really
importantly slots so you can have your
consumers pass in a slot of HTML and
then we've also got Shadow Dom which
I'll talk about a whole bunch which is
kind of really unique because you don't
have to deal with Shadow Dom as a normal
Dev but in the web component world it's
day to day you're going to have to deal
with this and it's awesome and prickly
at the same time
and all of these are web standards if I
go to the canonical can I use website
and search for web components you'll see
that it's green across the board for all
the Evergreen browsers except for the
obvious one which is Internet Explorer
but if we've been paying attention with
Internet Explorer
you know only last couple of weeks you
know Microsoft likes to end of life
we're not supporting it you shouldn't
support it it's not safe to use and is
it I can see some smiles
um and I think as a developer you've got
license now to go push back and say
we shouldn't be using it like it's just
not supported and it's really stopped
keeping up years ago
so this Shadow Dom thing is one of those
standards that I won't support but we
don't have to worry about that but it's
important because we get CSS
encapsulation from it so here we can see
a normal Dom tree that's in the light
Dom uh as we would say and we've got the
shadow host which is the start of our
web component
and that web component has its own
shadow tree or its own Dom tree that's
separate from the main Dom tree and
that's the important takeaway that you
have to cross through Shadow boundary
and that gives you this CSS
encapsulation and other encapsulation
that's awesome and a little bit prickly
at times so when you actually go look at
it when it's rendered out it looks like
this
light Dom main Dom tree normal HTML same
thing but just encapsulated in your
Shadow Dom for your web component
and this is what it would look like if
you inspect the tools looking at the
same thing you can see here in red this
is my shadowed on my own little very
tiny piece of HTML and I've got this
encapsulation of CSS and I've got my
shadow host outside of that red which is
this hollow dash world tag and this
ability to do this is great which I'll
run through now and also some things are
annoying
so one of the big challenges web
components for years and we're kind of
somehow it snuck up on us I went to the
polymer conference in
2016 in Europe and polymer was the big
hit and you know it took all that time
until we're now we're actually in the
real world building with them
um you know more uh prolifically so
over that time one of the challenges the
solve was it's great now I've got CSS
encapsulation I don't have these
clashing Styles all these bleeding CSS
but what about all the global styles
that I do want to control and not have
in every component and share well that's
where CSS variables have really been our
savior is another web standard that we
can use and if you're going to use web
components you're going to be all in
with CSS variables because they can
cross the shadow Dom
so here we've got the most simple one
with the dash dash notation at the front
which says this is a CSS variable and
you can set a value to it but you can
compose them which is great so here I
have another one which is a dash
dashboard a primary and I am using the
first CSS variable there inside of it
with the VAR function so they work very
similar to SAS variables they compile
very differently in terms of when
they're executed but in general they're
pretty similar so they're great and
you're going to be all in with web
components I can also do there's lots to
talk about I can do little overrides
like with this green here as well
and again same story green across all
the browsers for Evergreen you can use
these things you don't have to worry
about it too hard
um
and it one of the great things about
this we don't need to use all of these
naming strategies like bam or block
element modifier in the past I'd use
this quite a bit quite a neat little
Convention of having underscores and
double dashes to say this is a styling
for this component don't clash with that
component because I'll do things like
this where I'd put these prefixes and
these double dashes but I don't have to
do that anymore I can kind of go oh I
like it but I just don't need it I can
make my own button component don't ever
need to put a class on the top I could
and I can pass start using our company's
language with a variant of danger
and then inside of this web component
there's a couple of things to run
through here it's different with the way
you would style them with Shadow Dom
first of all this state danger at the
bottom I don't need to put button in
front of it I'm inside the shadow Dom I
can just simple things things get
simpler I don't have to worry about it
clashing with a drop down state Danger
and the other thing is this host here
you can see I'm using CSS variables
everywhere and this host is in the light
Dom and I'm saying these CSS variables
you can override those if you want and
we have natural namespacing by selecting
the shadow host which would be my dash
button open some braces and inside of
there I can just override this dash dash
color so it's a very different way
kind of cement or syntactically of
writing it but it kind of neatens
everything up now
these pixels that I've got here as well
are you we don't have too much of that
probably nine times out of ten what
you'd see is we will have a design token
that will come in from a different
Library that's Upstream from us like and
we'll compile them into CSS variables so
most of the time you're using named
things that are versioned and this is
really cleaning up a lot of our code in
terms of being able to have that
confidence to change these Styles across
many teams
other really cool thing about webcoons I
spend most of my time on these two dock
sites which is really cool rather than
spending all my time on the react or
angular or view sites and that's great
because these things are web standards
they move like glaciers you know they
don't come and go very quickly you can
really invest your time to learn them
and build with them because you're going
to take them to the next project to the
next project and so forth so that's one
of the really cool parts of using web
components
another really cool part of using web
you could do this in reactor angular or
view is stopping to bake in
accessibility but it's a big part for us
so I wanted to mention it that you could
do this if you're building edit not
using web components because if you have
a component like this a simple input
form
has a label and an input and you've got
this four property on the label and
you're saying hey this has got the same
ID as the input because now the
assistive screen reader can marry those
up know there's an association and make
a better call for the screen reader on
how to do this
easy at this point gets a little bit
harder for the developer when you add a
third element and you say oh but now you
need to know to do just stop the top of
your head to do an aria described by and
marry up the next ID so one thing you
can do is just be like well we're going
to own that we're going to make a
component so here's a my Dash input you
don't have to worry about any of that
stuff here's just what you need to give
us you want text not numbers you want to
label you want an error you know lots of
properties and we'll just render we'll
deal with all that accessibility for you
in one spot and if something goes wrong
with it and our accessibility team want
to change the way we do it we change it
here goes everywhere
okay because as I mentioned out of out
of the box accessibility big deal
um big companies they really can't
afford not to get this right
okay the grass isn't always greener with
web components I like to stop and share
some of the War Stories it's not all
ponies and unicorns on the beach so the
what are the prickly parts of this I
think the big one for me is you're going
to write more code with web components
you're going to write them
once you're going to test them once
you're going to ship them everywhere but
you're going to write more code and one
of those reasons is you know you're
wrapping all these native elements with
Shadow Dom so you would have this is an
extreme example but this is coming from
a library called crayons from freshworks
that are using stencil as a library to
write web components like we are I'm not
picking on it I really like their
Library I'm just using it as an example
to say
if you have an input with all these
native abilities that you can use you're
going to need to wrap it in some
shadowed arm and then you're going to
need to capture them on the host and
pass them down so you've got all these
different things here that you're going
to have to pass down so inputs have a
lot so placeholder Min length max length
min max read only required steps type
value I think you get the point and then
I've got to capture some of these events
on input on blur on focus and you can
see that I actually deal with these
events a lot and we have to keep
bubbling them up so you do this in other
component libraries but you do it a fair
bit more in web components so you're
going to write more code this is an
extreme example but even something like
a button or something else you think
about the native things that it has that
you also want in your button you're
going to need to double handle a bunch
of things
other part prickly that about web
components is forms so there's some
evolving standards for dealing with
forms in most of the browsers not Safari
and that means that stencil which we use
are like ah it's not quite there yet
here's a workaround for it they're like
baked in and bought in on that standard
yet for dealing with forms and the way
the problem is that you've got Shadow
Dom for a button so imagine you have a
submit button and in a normal form you
hit the submit button and it submits the
form it's just normal HTML
but if that button is your button and
it's a web component and it's inside of
Shadow Dom you hit the submit button and
it goes I don't know about a form
and
you're like oh
and you go down the rabbit hole but this
is copied from ionic who made sensor
which will go on go on to show you but
basically what they say is if if you hit
the submit button this is their work
around and
you're inside of a form and the way they
do that is they go I'm going to crawl
out of the dark the shadow Dom into the
light Dom with this element.closus you
know browsers can handle the performance
and it starts crawling out and goes oh
wait I am inside of a form
and it goes that's good now I'll do the
if statement it goes great make me a
fake button set its type make it
invisible jam it into the light Dom
click the thing and then remove it and
you're like oh
I'll just scoot this through my PR like
make sure no one sees it's easy to test
you can wrap it up into a Helper but
these are some of the edges around web
components that I say so I'm taking a
picture I'm going to get in trouble
um but that's something you've got to
think about and you're going to have to
deal with we do this it works it's not
too hard and in time this standard
around forms will just be there and
we'll not have to do some things like
this another thing server side rendering
so it's very very common in the front
end of the moment to render your HTML on
the server and node there's no browser
there so there's no Shadow Dom there so
you can't render HTML web component
there but all the main libraries have
some sort of work around for this the
sensors got you covered you can use
they'll compile out a version that can
run in the server lit has also got like
a beta thing that you can use and the
other one from Fast UI which is
Microsoft's web components which is
worth checking out they've just said hey
we've got a beta SSR as well so you end
up using a library to write your
components in anyway and they've all got
to work around
but my point is Shadow Dom's awesome
really love it but you work harder for
it and it's it's kind of unique you
don't have to deal with this in normal
Frameworks
all right so how do we write ours we use
stencil JS which
um I think is awesome and I'm going to
run through some of the awesome points
but I'll show you some Alternatives that
you could be using as well so the first
reason I really like stencil.js is a
library for writing our components is
that it's made from ionic and it's
battle hardened for that reason ionic
makes hybrid mobile apps and they had
this problem they're like we need people
to use react and angular and view but we
want them to use our components so they
made stencil to solve that problem so
you really get that feeling when you're
using stencil that they've solved this
problem before for millions of you know
people who use ionic and you can go
steal a lot of their code it's open
source not quite right for everyone's
project but you can still get a lot from
it so that's one of the big benefits of
using stencil in my mind is it's battle
hardened
the other thing is it's very much it's
pretty simple to use it's very much like
angular and react had babies I probably
just upset everybody and divided the
room but it is and it's for this reason
is the hollow World component in stencil
and it's like angular because they use
decorators so here you can see they've
got this decorator and they're
annotating the class saying hey stencil
this is the information you need to know
to make this a stencil component but
then at the bottom they've got
a render function and they're using jsx
or TSX it's all in typescript with
stencil so that's pretty cool I think
it's pretty easy if you've used the
front-end framework before first a
you'll get it you'll be up and running
and then you can spend your time to
master it
their dogs are awesome
easy to search quite small based on web
standards you don't spend too much time
here you spend more on the other docs
but they've kind of covered the stuff
that's edgy like bundling and styling
and give an opinion on those things
they also solve a really big problem
that you're going to face is that you're
still probably going to wrap your web
components to use with Frameworks like
react and angular so out of the box this
is all that you need to do for for
stencil to go great I'll take all of
your core web components I'll wrap them
in an angular wrapper and they'll deal
with all the lazy loading and making the
angular module and react modules and
making it in the react syntax of a
sentence case versus a spinal case and
so forth for your HTML elements so this
is really cool and it solves a lot of
the problem but what it doesn't do for
you
is package it up and put it on npm
that's a web thing you're still going to
have to go do that yourself you've got
to figure out how to deal with change
logs and Version Control and you're
going to need to go get NG packager so
you're still going to drop some time
here building your own packages but
they've solved this problem for you it
looks the same with react
um
it's pretty easy to get started they
have just a simple script you run and it
will spit out some folders like this and
you can get started using stencil here's
the opinionation of what unit testing
you should do and everything else works
great we use this and then when we want
to bring on a new design system that has
components that are specific to that
design system that don't make sense to
put in core we do this again and we just
put their ones over in their own one so
it's really good
it's doubled in size over the last two
years which is great because you can
find tax to your problems like that form
problem I showed you before there's
enough of the community people talking
about it which is always something
that's good when you're using a
framework
and web components in general they're
trending it's good so in my opinion
stencil is awesome but it's not not the
only one that you should look at
um you know we all got to be careful
when we choose technology so if you're
at the very beginning of this journey
you're looking what web what component
web component compiler should I use I
think probably the other big one to look
at is from Google called lit element so
I'm not going to go into a deep
comparison of the two you can go do that
I just want to point out that it's
awesome as well and it's worth checking
out it's the next incarnation of polymer
which was their first kind of web
component Library
and if you compare them next to each
other not to say one's better than the
other you can see lips more popular more
downloads every month
um but really what I think is
interesting here is they're both
trending up so that's really cool we're
seeing more people have a crack at web
components in the wild and more
downloads but
it's still a bit of a niche if you
if you bring in react
then
you know you're in the hundreds of
thousands and these other big Frameworks
are in the millions so it's something to
consider you know when you're doing your
due diligence when you're picking a new
framework
all right moving on to talk about uh
design tokens and how do we get them in
code
so this is a really
important one and every day that I'm
working on this project because I don't
just get to focus purely on the
components even though they're the most
fun bit to me
um is that this has the biggest impact
to affect more teams and have a broader
ability to solve a problem and engage
both parties
so as I said they just
key value pairs
but they're platform agnostic so they're
not already in CSS they're just key
value Pairs and you transform them to
where you want them so you might want
them in Android you might want them in
flutter all sorts of places
and they look like this
and
you're probably looking at this like me
I always annoying my designer I'm like
hey here's another one from the wild and
I'm going to get blocked soon but it's
good because you're gonna have to run
around looking at how everyone's doing
this because there's no simple way of
doing it you're gonna have to come up
with your convention so here we've got
Spectrum Dash which is Adobe spectrum is
the design system Global for the space
or the level
color static blue 600 is the scale and
it's set to Blue and you're like yeah
it's pretty yuck name
um
but it makes sense there's not just
enough context here so these names are
really tricky and it's a huge Rabbit
Hole like we've spent hundreds of hours
across our team trying to figure out how
to name these things and workshopping
with the broader parties because it is
really difficult naming stuff it's one
of the you know top three things in
software that's difficult and it's also
really difficult in design to name stuff
and I wish I could just pick up a book
and just be like oh yeah we'll just do
it like they did and we're finished but
you can't it's much harder than that and
I'll give you a bit of an inside why so
let's
look at this thing it's platform
agnostic I don't even need to use dashes
I can use dots whatever I want so button
dot primary dot color and I can point to
another design token
and then compose them together and at
this point you're probably going yeah
that looks pretty simple
you're like yeah but we should probably
make sure it doesn't clash with other
people we know where it came from so
let's put the name of the company there
so MC for my company I couldn't think of
anything better
so my
company.button.primary.color points to
my company dot color dot primary
and then we go on and we say oh we
should probably say what level it's at
so we're dealing with a component level
and that's important because I get
context but the other side's at a
reference level
and every company uses different names
for component and reference it's just
wild
um and so this reference level is kind
of higher up it's reused by more it's
more common but this component level is
more low level so I kind of want that
context and it's starting to get a lot
more verbose and then I go what if this
is the primary color on a dark surface
and then it gets harder yeah and you can
see where I'm going with this and then
what if it's on a dark surface but
you're also hovering on this dark
surface and now you've got a token on a
dark hovered surface and you're like oh
yeah WTF Duncan you don't do this do you
really that's a terrible name but if you
go look at more more things in the wild
this is from Material Design This is
they've got some good docs they've only
started this journey themselves they've
only gotten to colors and typography but
they've got examples of lots of things
so they go MD for material design and
then they've got component for the level
Fab for the actual component secondary
for the variant and then they're talking
about label text and then they're
talking about the actual font of the
label text so you're going to end up
looking at this going up to seems too
much and that's a challenge we have to
express to all the design parties that
we've reached this point because
verbose names give us all the context
and we can scale
But It's Tricky there is a Design Group
on w3c they've just started I think
they've this is a little out of date I
think they've just released their next
draft the other week but it
unfortunately there's not enough there
yet for us just to pick it up and use
their standards so we have to come up
with ours and we have to spend the time
to do it we're mostly there we're all
excited about it but it's taken time
but again it's really important I I'm
put on my
you know a web developer hat but it's
really important between the both
parties of designers and developers it's
like that glue between the two because
there's that air gap where we're copying
and pasting code across and there's that
communication gap where we're not
necessarily working as one team sharing
that code base and that language
properly unless we have these sorts of
design tokens so you might not use web
components at all but this design token
stuff might be interesting to you to
start emulating at your work so the
other thing that I'm realizing from this
is that I probably need to step back
from this journey as the web developer
because I'm kind of Downstream of a lot
of this action Upstream with the
designers and the decision making and
I'm trying to let go of the naming and
let them do it all but as a developer
naming you know it's close to our hearts
we like to argue about it for hours but
it I feel like it I need to let go of it
and let them be in charge just so it'll
flow down to us otherwise we're not
going to build this awesome team
so we use a DSP who's heard of a DSP
before
okay nobody all right so it's kind of
new so this is from Adobe DSP is a
standard basically for getting your
design tokens into Jason you're going to
have to figure out a way to do this
um Adobe use it because they made it
material design recommended it's on
their docs and we're using it it's a
kind of a fringy space but this is how
we get our design tokens into code and
there's I'll walk you through it now but
basically it's a standard it's open
source and it looks like this so we have
our designers and developers in Visual
Studio code open up the XD plugin that
you get just like a normal plugin in
your Visual Studio code editor and XD
has a wysiwyg style
GUI that you can author tokens and
documentation in markdown and code
Snippets for your components and all of
those sorts of things
it under the covers goes to Json and
then you can compile it out to whatever
platform you want
so it kind of looks like this we have a
DSP that's its own neutral space for
designers and developers to author these
tokens and it can go back Upstream to
Adobe because they made it and it can
come down from an XD the design tool
into the DSP we don't do that that'd be
a total mess but you can go back and
forth but we go from this DSP out to a
package manager and through all the
normal code stuff we do a pull request
we do a code review we run through CI CD
where we compile all these tokens from
raw key value pairs out to all the
different consumers so we go to web and
our web people needs SAS and they need
CSS variables so it's just a compile
step it's cheap we just do everything so
they can have both and then there's lots
of teams that can have access to that so
it's no longer copying and pasting stuff
around which is really great and this
whole thing would work the same if we
just went to mobile as well they could
get flutter variables out of those
design tokens I know that flutters are
happy good choice okay
so we can kind of expand our Horizon but
this is kind of where I'm going
there's this little guy down here
I need to let go and push this back
upstream and think more big picture
because they're not my design tokens
unfortunately if I bake them into our
component Library that's used by lots of
devs
unfortunately you'll never probably make
it back upstream and I would have named
them for us and I'll we'll just copy and
paste them into the next Library we'll
do and we're back to square one
so this is solving lots of problems for
us other really cool thing about this is
you can have Visual Studio code Snippets
so our developers when they npm install
into their projects the DSP they get all
these tokens they can just search in the
command palette for a design token or
they can search for a component and they
can see company name button space bar
and they say react angular button and
they go oh yeah I'll take this one plops
it into their IDE and then they can
click on it and it takes them to the
docs so all of that's really cheap to
set up it's pretty cool
okay last section moving on to talking
about tools and packaging because
there's a lot of different stuff that
you need to do
we don't have a website yet for this
because they're expensive to build
documentation sites so when you're
building a component in my team there's
actually nowhere no website to spin up
all we have is Storybook and
there's a couple of other tools that are
unique but that's one of the big things
here is that with storybook we're all in
so we use store who's using storybook
here
okay fair few people it's kind of the
king of the castle in this space
um so
we use it for everything develop review
test design sharing with other people
documentation it's all we really have at
the moment will eventually grow up and
have enough time to build another
documentation site for all of our stuff
but for now it's all in here
so this is what it looks like it's just
a really simple canvas where you can
stick a component or a series of
components or a whole web page of
components on there and you can change
all the attributes so people can go in
there and disable it and click on it and
see how it all works you can flip this
the theme to dark you can switch to
another design system and all these
sorts of things so we invest quite
heavily in this this is just a very
basic example of a button but I think
you get the picture but we use lots of
plugins in the storybook and they're
what I think is really cool so here we
have a plugin for taking the design
tokens in DSP because it's just the
transform step we annotate those as they
come out and then we can use someone
else's plugin to then visually look at
those in the storybook and if the design
token changes it just recompiles and
flows through so it's really nice
we have an accessibility plugin so the
plugin at the bottom is showing you here
you know you've got some issues with
your accessibility in a normally 30 to
50 percent of those low level easy to
automate kind of problems with
accessibility we can see just as we
first make our component we can see it
kind of saying it's not accessible yet
and we can have some help there
and we put our docs in here stencil is
really good stencil
looks through your code looks at your JS
docs in there and makes a really good
readme this is a very miniature one but
all your properties events and so forth
and it makes a readme file so for us we
just make a component we make a story
a story file and we make a readme file
and the story file just points to this
and we have a tab so anyone who wants to
dive into our docs they're there and we
don't have to write any documentation
site either it's quite good
so moving on from storybook another tool
or a process or a thing that you're
going to have to decide on is how are
you going to do a mono Reaper because
you're probably going to end up needing
one if you're lucky
you just ship core components but it's
probably unlikely probably going to ship
core components and then a react version
of those core components in an angular
version of those core components and
there's three three different packages
and then you might have you know
specific packages for icons maybe but
then as soon as you bring on another
design system and you want to have a
package for that just for the components
that are just for that other design
system then you're going to need another
package and another angular another rack
so straight away at six or seven and
then you've got five Design Systems or
eight Design Systems and we compile a
lot of this we don't necessarily
maintain that code but you need a tool
for being able to deal with that so we
took off with learner and then it's
interesting and kind of middle or start
of this year learner kind of died and
then we were like oh we're going to move
on and then NX kind of brought over the
owner or came the custodians of the
learner but it was too late for us we
just went with npm workspaces it's kind
of settling down it's just got this nice
Turf Syntax for being able to handle
lots of different packages and being
able all to have shared node modules and
all the things we wanted for us and it's
just so much tinier and easier love an
expert not this time yarn's good we just
went with npm
um
something that helps us because of the
Simplicity of npm is plop so plop is a
really cool library for being able to
have like a little CLI where you can
enter in variables and ask to generate
files like generate a component and make
a component file a test file a story
file and so forth so we plop our
components and we plop our angular and
react outputs and we plop whole
onboarding of new little stencil kits
for people a new Design Systems come in
so I'm a huge fan of plop I find it
really good it kind of balances out this
really lightweight ability of npm
workspaces and I'll definitely be you
know using plop and plopping lots of
files into future projects I find it a
quite a neat utility to use handlebars
it's quite good
who's using plop
nobody okay interesting everyone's got
an awesome framework that's just pumping
out their code gen for them yeah okay
all right I'm gonna finish off
um rabbiting on a little bit about these
two as well we use both we use SAS and
we use post CSS so we use the SAS for
the component level styling and we use
post CSS for lots of different things
but it's really interesting for me like
several years ago when we started using
SAS it really kind of shined this light
on
oh questions okay so we really shine
this light on
all of this cleanup it really brought
all these new opportunities into our CSS
world we suddenly got namespacing we've
got variables we got nesting we got all
this Imports and us CSS just went to the
next level but now with post CSS for me
several years on I'm kind of going wow
this has got everything SAS can do and
more I'm kind of seeing that same
opportunity to pick up this next level
in how we're doing our CSS because I can
do everything SAS can do but I can do
more and I find when I'm using post CSS
I can use a plugin that will be like
you can go use the latest web standards
before they're ready in draft level one
two three for example and you can choose
How brave you want to be pulling in
those web standards early and when I
need to go look at how those web
standards work I'm back on the web
standards docs not on the SAS website
learning about what's coming and using
it now and to me that's awesome so I
really like that so I think this will
probably be my last project where I use
SAS love it but I think I'm just gonna
stay with post CSS
one last quick shout out is to Smashing
Magazine so if you want to not so much
web components but you want to learn
about Design Systems and you want to go
sit for hours with people like Brad
Frost and Nathan Curtis in workshops you
know remotely they have awesome
workshops big fan if you're into Design
Systems it's really worth checking out I
think it's the the spot to go at the
moment to learn the space
so in summary what have we covered today
we had a look at the team that you need
to pull this off we had a look at why
where we're using web components and
we're bullish on web components we
looked at the stencil Library we're
using we looked at design tokens as code
and we looked at some of the tooling so
I just want to say a big thank you for
coming to my talk today and if you're in
the hallways or you're having a cool
beverage in the evening come grab me
um love to talk about this stuff and
thank you very much
foreign
if we have if anyone wants to ask any
questions
at what scale would you start
recommending going down this path
that's small I've got friends who do a
lot of Blazer is that okay no no okay is
that Blazer okay that's fine okay so
um
so I have friends who do a fair bit of
Blazer not ssw I know Adam loves Blazer
um but they have net and server-side
stuff and they've got some razor pages
and they build their headers with web
components because they can use it in
angular and net so they've just got a
little bit they've been doing this for
years and they get a lot of advantages
out of that so you can do a little bit
of it if you need to cut across
different platforms but
I I am bullish about web components but
you need to have that problem because
it's much easier if you're just going to
stay in a silo and Crush out that
framework yeah so the next big jump to
where you're making components I think
you'd need to have some wild card like a
big big investment in a CMS or something
that's just not reactor angular review
does that answer the question
um
we can find it out front
yeah yeah yeah so the question of like
you've already got lots of reactor now
you just want to start slowly using web
components yeah that is very easy
especially with Shadow Dom because you
know a lot of that strong barrier of
styling is baked into it and Native so
it's very easy to pull them in so you
know we're going to be putting these
things into you know big sites that have
been running for years and we're going
to start by owning the header because we
can own a whole space and then we'll do
buttons and drop downs and all these
sorts of things so here it is easy for
that reason because the Styles can just
be there but one of the the trickier
Parts is that you already have a global
CSS style sheet that comes together as a
big style sheet those Styles won't bleed
through for you unless you're using CSS
variables and you don't want them to so
you you still have to tackle getting
those Styles into the existing react
system and the
web component yeah
um
across the CSS like you described
other stuff wouldn't share as expected
JavaScript was political or wasn't
something like that does that sound
familiar yeah and that's
CSS there so the so the question that
you're asking around you know previously
a few years back we had a real challenge
because we had encapsulation and we
could hide our CSS we should have done
but we couldn't actually get across it
very well so CSS variables are the
answer to that but as I was mentioning
because they can just natively cut
straight across if you use one inside
it's like it's Global
um but the stuff around some of the
javascripts like the form element and
getting in and out of that shadow Dom
that stuff's close to being fixed but
not perfect yet
um but there's ways around most of those
things and they're becoming less and
less so it's much less of a problem like
it's realistic in 2022 where you're
using web components lots of people are
as you saw this like between those two
libraries there's almost a million
downloads a month but so it's much
better and it's getting better but those
inherent problems are still kind of
there to deal with because of Shadow Dom
yeah but definitely the last two years
has been just snuck up Wilderness and
now it's a standard so yeah
you get with the components that you
provide to your customers
because whenever I've looked at design
tutorials and invariables
I work on back office applications which
are really just data tables and forms of
various very complexity
my concerns with
with designs are about you know how
paddings or fields and
and you know how text boxes lay out you
know
you know versus a mobile
s
you solved those sort of problems with
your Sciences I I've kicked them out of
our team's responsibility to the
designers where it should be and that's
what the design tokens do so the design
tokens when you start you'll just have
you know helpers like padding like a
scale of spacing primary colors and so
forth but as you get more Rich into it
you will actually also build out tokens
for components so you will have a you
know your brand name dot modal Dot
padding and you can actually use a named
variable that's standard across the
company for the padding on that model
but that's quite a robust setup yeah
that's kind of further down the road
when you've got all your components also
in in tokens
a lot of the time that's just still in a
CSS file so for us we absolutely tackle
that we make
specific CSS files for our components
for each of the big players which is the
design system in our space so we'll have
a toggle you can just pass in a
different CSS file for that modal or for
that whole brand and that will then just
apply all those styles to all the
components for the consumer so when they
use a modal or a button that the
developer doesn't think about it it's
already done they just have the Styles
there they just use it they can override
it but
that's the beauty is that they just plop
them on there and they're already styled
ready to go they might do some layout
bit of spans like you know media queries
and stuff but yeah
so so basically the developer laying out
a form which sort of still draws a
digital spans to say you know give label
totally and I think that's a really
important I think it's important that we
don't solve everything for the developer
or we'll just spin our Wheels trying to
make websites that are completely
configurable and that's too hard so we
very much pass the buck to the
development team for a lot of things we
have a design token for H1s they can go
use it but we're not going to make a H1
for them we're not going to position two
components next to them because as soon
as we have to account for that decision
making it's just way too difficult to
know what they want so here's a card you
go stick it on your page and and you go
it's got all the perfect padding on it
but how it sits next to the next one you
know here's something you can copy but
that's that's up to you because it's
hard to know up up front
who's excited for web components did I
scare everybody off
oh okay people are nice that most of the
hands went up yeah I I think it's it's
you can do it now but it'll get better
and better yeah for sure
any other questions
oh okay I think
um
depends which compiler you're using like
if you're using
um lit or stencil so if you're going to
be using stencil I really like ionic
because they made it and they've got
their own components so you can just go
look through their Source control and
there's a couple of other in that space
like crayons but if you're in the lit
space there's a really awesome open
source library that you could just use
in your own components you don't have to
write the web component you can go use
it called shoelace so shoelace is really
good that one's written with lit so it
kind of depends which path you go down
because you're probably going to choose
you know if you go with fast UI from
Microsoft they've got they're just
starting to kind of open it up to make
it more themeable and better for
everybody so fast UI is another one you
might have a look at
looking at the time
we're going to finish a few minutes
early
that is good
what's everyone going to next
don't know
what's that
coffee machine nice
are you still there yeah sorry I don't
understand the question
yeah it's good that we don't have to
deal with that yeah but if you really
miss it not I know you get nostalgic
about these
yeah yeah
all right well thank you very much
everybody I feel free to grab me
whenever over the conference um yeah and
enjoy cheers